uh dane cook would make out with you
nick schwartzen here's the question
definitely bill bellamy yeah
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
[Music]
throw them up throw them up pop pop pop
pop this one's gonna be right at the
camera
dude we're balling look at all these
cameras we're balling
we stole howard stern set what's up
howard stern just signed that 600
million dollar deal
diddy yup howard stern did 120 a year he
said joe rogan hold my bear dog
he got more than rogan yeah unbelievable
well yeah
he did well the overall deal yeah
wow rogan's like deshawn watson and then
um
howard stern's like uh patrick mahomes
longer deal more money more money but
then one's more entertaining than the
other
rogan's way better let's be real guys we
have a new studio
new studio huh yeah i walked in and was
like where am i
new studio also nick's new apartment yes
nick's new version let's be real that
couch is way too comfortable for just
the culture corner
i did find a pair of boxers back there
in the morning [ __ ] knew it
we should uh episode 100 we got a
special guest here all the way from
is it fair to say nashville d you can i
don't know where you're at
i don't know i don't wear no more dog
you're just a roadie i'm a [ __ ]
lot lizard dog yeah
doug where are you living these days
look at that
oh damn dog that shit's fly thank you
bro
that quarantined uh haircut yeah but i'm
keeping it afraid it's coming in thick
man have you uh
you've been treating it or something
would you do auditioning and you know
what i'm saying letting my girl play in
it oh
yeah let's just stop you thinking about
breaking through you think about
breaking it up maybe yo i'm thinking i'm
gonna get like the [ __ ] lamar jackson
yeah
that is not derek's hair come on baby
that's me that's a goal right
that's the goat that's george jefferson
right there man
i think i feel like everyone during
quarantine's growing their hair out look
at my [ __ ] i'm actually uh
put some highlights in it tomorrow and
counting it to a man bun
who do you think george jefferson or uh
richard jefferson
in a fight overall
way from the nets yeah rg talking about
rj
now rj hosts a podcast now and they have
lebron on there every other week crying
about something
well right lebron was like kyrie hurt my
feelings he said i'm not a clutch
shooter like [ __ ] you're
worth a billion dollars why the [ __ ] you
care what other people say do you think
here though
would say look wise actually just
overall
who would you rather be you think
richard or uh is the guy on the left
oh or is homeboy on the left dead
george passed away yeah yeah he's
george's face god he was talented yeah
man
yeah super machine rj is a beast too
though now
want some rings with the miami heat but
where where did uh rj grow up where the
because jefferson came from like the
bottom man he worked his way up
here yeah yeah to the east side he's
back to a deluxe apartment
in the sky they did it man
george was born in harlem wow
236 episodes of the jeffersons born in
harlem
in 1929 yep wow
and then rj he i bet it was some place
with a silver spoon in his mouth he
seemed yeah i'd rather be george
oh wow you guys are hating on all rookie
teams his parents are christian
missionaries around frequently growing
up he had attended movie valley
born in l.a and then went to school in
phoenix
there you go phoenix represent dog shout
out to phoenix baby
wow so yeah i'm saying george jeff i'm
saying you know george jefferson
looks like he owns the hottest walk in
l.a look at him yeah dude
dude we're in a new studio jackson
talking about it the new studio
yeah yeah it's very howard stern shout
out to nick davis and his girl setting
this up man
they did it overnight bro it looks great
in here this is so
dope nick and a large majority of today
as you guys were here for
when we did it but we have 19 cameras
now
are we in 3d we have been actually uh
uh three or three sixty on patreon meet
me at 20. you can see the whole
you can see the whole studio in the room
wow i still have no idea what that looks
like though
i've never seen it yeah i've never seen
it can they now fans can uh pick the 3d
or 360 option zoom in on cat's feet and
mouth
okay here's the thing if anyone's going
to make money off of my feet it's going
to be me
well get to it
i think people would do out there you
know they ain't just in defeat
yeah maybe i should start only fans then
if people are zooming in anyways
yeah charge a little extra dollar and
then you can zoom in whatever you want
oh well maybe not whatever you want you
zoom in on uh theo's upper lip
whatever you want dog mm-hmm see it get
it wait the upper lip why not the bottom
lip
the ball i feel like that's
oh [ __ ] is he live
he is not oh thank god i'm not ready for
this but he's still alive
yeah yeah damn look at that grill son
gorilla baby
dude and he ripped on [ __ ] little
brows album
ripped it he did have you heard that
track yet i haven't heard it yet
you haven't heard the thick boy anthem
either oof with mike stud and jelly roll
huh do you got that album nick oh wait i
have heard some of it yeah
i'm going to try to get the paw wall one
from brows as we uh
catch the anthem right now with mike
stud and [ __ ] uh jelly roll
are we gonna have a like a album
listening party
uh we should we should that can be the
next cast after dark
damn yeah that's a good idea turn up in
here but
paul wall uh as did a number of people
uh
was proud of us for reaching 100 100
episodes
a couple people sent in congratulations
videos and we'll start with paul's feel
free to stop him at any time uh maybe
not paul's but like we got some other
characters that you might want to
react to what it does
gotta send big congrats out big congrats
to the king of the thing
d.o brendan what's up baby
100 episodes in okay
yeah man i'm able to be a
guest on one of your episodes can't wait
to come back man pushing man you know
i'm a big fan love y'all man
100 episodes
i love it wow bro looks like using a
phantom or some [ __ ]
dude man that's crazy who would have
known when we started this journey paul
wall would be a fan
and featured in it and he's got that
enamel is just bedazzled man that's a
beautiful
you still haven't got a front from him
uh-uh i gotta go when i go to houston
i'm gonna go down there
because it hit that's bedazzled up that
is
now would you would you get bedazzled
would you do just the bottom are you
gonna do top
and bottom see i think you should just
bottom that [ __ ] would look lit
oh yeah i think i can't you can't see my
bottoms very much so
we smile right only if i do like that
because otherwise
oh you got an underbite or overbite one
of them
yeah they don't tell you which is which
it's like no i'll tell you
yeah you have an underbody why'd you ask
me because i i
oh just though
come on bro right and i can do that
right there yeah see i want just one
gold one
just oh like an auntie like a like a
like a wet band
yeah yeah like a hunty yeah dog i feel
like i would go for either the fangs or
the one like diamond on
one of those now that gabby labby who we
had last episode
she had now i think she has one she had
one i i think it was a crystal i don't
think it was a diamond i think it's a
crystal she had a geode or something
giad yeah
i think i think it was cool i don't
think it was a real diamond she had that
g audio call me crazy
look at this that's all of those things
nice grills
that's what chappelle can do with his
gap just fill it in with a
little diamond hey
baby come on yeah get that diamond back
strap in the middle chapelle
nick's got one too he could do it too
nick's got to do it with me nick looks
like paul wall did like an amish
yeah paul's over the wall and out into
the world
i gotta confess guys he's not even a fan
of the show it's been me the whole time
yeah damn he looks cool he did a good
job
skin looks good he lost weight he's
killing it man
uh his wife does workout videos too
didn't he say that does she do what does
she do
is she like a instagram like fitness
instructor fitness ladies and gentlemen
she's a fitness yeah a little fit lady
um is she furry working on her fitness
and wear her witness
i i don't know i know jelly rolls girl
does the only fans thing and she's
killing it
she does amazing for herself yeah she
got him that rolex was
oh yeah huh they're all go that old
diamond rolly
he's got himself a boss if she's
bringing in that type of money
yeah must be nice that only fan's bad
yep
what do i do on it my question is
immediately no
my answer is immediately no brandon uh
open opportunity
as they say in the streets depends what
i have to do on there i'm trying to post
some dick pics all the time but what if
someone wants like
photos of you and a thong just like
behind like your ass
yeah i feel like it's a bad look i got
kids
and then people screenshot it and think
it's blasted out like our boy yeah but
like
like his dick pic went viral yeah but
that was good
i think it went well for him yeah he has
a great day that's a good move yeah it's
a good move very good
way better than captain america's dick
big oh yeah yeah that wasn't
captain america's wasn't bad it was just
he could have done better there could
have been a better photo yeah yeah
it was like brett favre what else you
got nick
we have 19 cameras yes but uh yeah
that's not the only guy who sent in a
video
we got paul wall baby i'm the people's
channel
oh [ __ ] you're looking sleepy baby oh
it's uh chrissy uh
chrissy teigen it's chrissy this [ __ ]
yeah chrissy fat ass i don't know
chrissy whatever he says he has a face
for tv and a body for radio
huh yeah he has a body yeah he has a
body of like a he has kind of like an
ice skater body he's like
didn't he kiss you on the show what what
what did he get
you on christmas stefano not apollo
anton oh no and she is correct chris
christopher stephano he tried to but i
was straight
you pushed him away did you tell him no
means no huh
i told him no one time
look something that uh people aren't
doing right now is spending time with
one another
dude you know like cook together stay
together maybe your friend died maybe
your friend didn't
what i'm telling you right now is that
uh you can get great meals
from hellofresh yes daddy
yes hello fresh they got burgers they
got meatloaf what do you need
they got salmon slices everything yeah
yes sir
you listen you want to be a dope ass
chef you're going to look like going
with hello
fresh go to hellofresh.com 80 cats
use the code 80 cats get 80 off and
free shipping sun yup some companies
they don't even get you to write stuff
you you say you joined
the group and they send your damn chef's
hat and say good luck buddy
yep not here though not here the
ingredients oh these are fresh
ingredients and they got all kinds of
stuff it doesn't matter if you're trying
to be vegan
if you're trying to be military
non-military if you're trying to
just have fish or just have soup they
have everything it can be for family it
can be for
uh just a couple and it's fresh and
hello
fresh listen go to hellofresh.com
80 cats use the code 80 cats get 80 off
including free shipping get it now
yup that's right you can get hello fresh
and you can also switch between their
partners green chef and every plate
when your tastes change and you want to
eat a little bit differently
yup mix it up go to hellofresh.com
8-0-k-a-t-s
and use code 8-0-k-a-t-s to get 80 off
including free shipping dog when it
comes to meat i know you know your way
around some meat deal and when it comes
to meat we talk about quality meat
meat matters that's why butcher box is
part of this show cause guess what
you want 100 grass-fed finished beef
free-range
chicken we're not talking about them
locked up chickens talking about free
range happy chickens we're talking about
heritage breed pork what are you talking
about
salmon come on daddy talk about that
meat for your stupid mouth
get away from me man i'll tell you this
bro if you want grass-fed beef you got
to get grass-fed beef dog can i put my
meat on your grill
no you cannot sir you're a hater what
i'm talking about is they got finished
beef as well
sometimes you get a piece of beef and it
don't even you know it's not finished
well look
it's still happening uh the the cat you
know it's still
trying to run off yeah how about every
month butcherbox ships a curated
selection of high quality meats right to
your crib
some of you get meat that's still in a
coma i said damn i want finished beef
finish it up man butcher box is a
no-brainer it's the best meat shipped
right to your door which means
one less trip to the grocery store what
i'm talking about is with butcher box
you get the highest quality meat
for about six dollars on me oh god
that's nuts
bacon for life is back i got to tell you
that people you know people been
wandering around
they found a guy in the woods and he and
he probably died but before he did he
said he's baking for life coming back
and i said yeah you stupid hoe bacon for
life right now new members can get bacon
for life when you sign up just go to
butcherbox.com
cats that's a package of free bacon in
every box for the rest
of your subscription when you go to
butcherbox.com
cats let's see this babe
hey what's up theo and brendan um just
want to say congratulations on the
hundredth episode
of king and the sting um you know thank
god
you guys got on joe rogan when you did
and now you're both multi-fucking
millionaires
okay so just thank christ
i would get that on my knees every day
and lick his balls yeah
okay that's for very good lord above
that you got on the joe rogan show two
to three years ago and
absolutely exploded and now you're
[ __ ]
multi-millionaire i live in a
three-floor walk-up
[Laughter]
i love you bruh
i live in a three-floor walk-up
amazing unbelievable i love the zoo
he gave you another little kiss
would you kiss him if you had to kiss
another comedian that was a man
brendan who would it be besides joe
rogan i'll probably go bobby lee
because he's real smooth like a little
age and he's that's fair he's a little
feminine
as long as he shaved that mustache would
gross me out he's not gonna shave for
you brendan you have to
it's not like you get to choose how he
is he you take him as he is
he seems like a tender man that maybe he
makes you mad for you
maybe you don't can't just like you
can't like i don't know the rules of
kissing male
comics you don't own him brendan who
would you would you
i've never thought about it but there
you have it uh give us your top
five top five
yeah give us our mice there's only four
brendan
uh let me think i feel like you'd make
out living or dead
i feel like you'd make out with bert how
about one literally
not dead
um i mean burn has nice eyes but he's
not handsome dude and he doesn't he
he just i don't like him he's too hairy
i like him
sorry i just i would not not to kiss
he's too hairy
cuddling he's good yeah he does seem
cuddly yeah i don't know who that's a
good question man
mullany no he's not harry i'm thinking
not harry
[Laughter]
i don't want harry bobby lee might be
the best way to go if you don't want
harry sebastian
i think sebastian because he also has
like kind of like an
artistic type of like a concierge type
of vibe
yeah i feel like i would i would kiss
him and i'd know where the best
restaurant in town was
like he whispers a little secret it
would just show up in my head after the
kiss like oh
okay oh joe coy might be a good one to
make it okay
yeah he hasn't been shaving recently
though he has not yep
but he is half asian so you know the
smoothie he looks smooth
oh he is he has that stubble though i'm
not feeling the stubble
yeah i think i would go i f ooh harry
i'm gonna go sebastian
it's like i think no homo bruh but
sebastian you know but no
no what about andrew schultz
he's not harry at all he has facial hair
though he has that like
that wario mustache like facial hair
thing going on for him
no no who would you go with derek
it's really it's hard it's hard bro
cause i like a lot of dudes out there
man
yeah i feel you it's hard to choose once
yeah bro yeah no no
chess chill you want me to rattle some
off for you yeah
i'm thinking sebastian because that's
what my head i was because he said not
my type
he wasn't my type but that's what i like
about him santino
no he's aggressive you know he'll kiss
right bill burr
i feel like bill bird we'd kiss then
yeah punch me i don't know
does he know how he doesn't seem like
that you that kid that knows i don't
think he kisses
yeah could you imagine him kissing
somebody i couldn't no never yeah
never very hard to imagine yeah we'll
move on once derek answers
why you putting me on like that dog
uh dane cook would make out with you
nick schwartzen
here's the question definitely bill
bellamy yeah
i [ __ ] the [ __ ] out you bill all right
what up this
is a gangster dog i think that's what
brendan likes though
but i'd go just named all black comics
i'd let preacher lawson jack me up
on love i'm changing mine bro
cat williams yeah my gift is a savage
oh i'd make out with kevin hart because
i'd have to bend down come all big
yeah yeah hold him in your arms like a
koala yeah
woohoo will be cool yeah i'll put him on
those pouches
i put my kids in
yeah i'm gonna go with marlon wayans
actually okay yeah marlon wayans yeah
because marlon's almost it would be a
handsome woman even we've seen it white
chicks oh yeah
yeah he's a beautiful white woman you
can always close your eyes and just
imagine that
yeah yeah i might go with mark curry
oh mark norman i feel like he's soft he
doesn't have fish that's a good one too
very non-threatening yeah and i feel
like if you
were gay yeah
oh yeah you're gay i don't know i don't
know if he still doesn't use clothes out
he goes
i'm gay and i'm kevin hart
so jews
he's the best that's my time i'm kevin
hart and i'm gay and he leaves
i don't know what he does
so i walk into your vagina
funny guys are always dangerous for
girls because you never see it coming
suddenly
he's just he's bagged you really you're
laughing one moment and then suddenly
you're sleeping within the night
yeah i can see mark norman killing it
wow yeah i didn't think that
anything what's this nick uh would you
guys jack shore man yeah you guys kiss
jack shore
no no harry he sent in a video for us
what's up guys it's the king and the
stings here at welshman jack shaw
i want to say a big congrats to brendan
and theo and the
whole crew they on the first hundred
episodes some of the funniest stuff i've
seen in my life so uh
the first hundred before the roof and
i'm sure the knacks ended up even better
gang gang buzz buzz buzz buzzing jack
jack boss buzz buzz
chappelle gets excited anytime he hears
an accident from the uk you know he's
aroused right now with that oasis clock
above his head oh yeah where did he say
he's from he's not from manchester he's
from wells yeah he's from
that's right yeah he's a welshman you
guys are bros now right yeah we're like
good friends because we're oasis fans
you guys be
jamming each other's pictures oh we deem
each other all the time yeah i bet you
do play he's a champ when's his next
fight
we know who chappelle would kiss i
kissed ufc fighters dogs
yeah at least he's not kissing some lame
ass comic
yeah you're right you know what i'm
saying at least he can defend you in the
streets
yeah yeah at least if there's spousal
abuse abuse in your relationship you
people will understand it'll be on him
it's a fair fight it's fair
yeah he's a beast who's he fighting next
i think he he what he had a fight
against khalid taha
but it got cancelled someone had coveted
but i don't know what he's got
damn he's a fighter nothing on nothing
on the docket yet
uh and then we got a video from one of
our favorites
oh
hey y'all i'm out here in kansas today
freezing my butt off
me and dad are actually starting on as a
little hunting cabin
on our land out here but i wanted to
congratulate
brandon and theo today for their 100th
episode of kingdom estate
call me brandon you all are doing great
thank y'all enough for having me on the
show and let me be a part of the family
so y'all keep doing what you're doing
appreciate y'all
you and i think we have to fight to the
death for hannah's love huh
we have to fight to the death for
hannah's love well considering she said
theo
yeah but yeah but she's from the south
so they can't brandon
they can't say brandon yeah so i think
theo's in the clubhouse uh brandon
oh she was saying brendan oh yeah she
was saying yeah it's just a southerner
yeah she got that toy
dude we should do it like uh love island
have you ever seen love island
yeah i think i have we should do that
yeah and she has to pick oh that would
be interesting they can't a [ __ ] pick
yeah i'll do it i'll [ __ ] do it right
now
baby yeah
would have been your this would have
been your ex-wife derek
you like you weren't there with that
episode though i'm like right there man
lion lips go hard i ain't [ __ ] look
at her wine lips
baby wine house lip right brandon
end
thank you for having me be a part of
your magical journey get that snake out
girl
i mean sylvia could be here with you
guys hold on i'm getting a message
important message is coming from here
oh damn
dude you need all right
remember yeah dude i laughed so hard
when she was she had to change she
didn't even change she was showing me
her tattoo she turned around
she was all that bad ass well we were
all just staring it feels like that ass
darren take that ass out derek is so
confused
because she's shaking her ass and you're
all like yeah and i'm like oh yeah
yeah she did it yeah she was a guest in
culture corner brought a snake
and then she was showing cat her tattoo
and pulled her pants down she was like
on her thigh so she had to like face
towards you she's a dancer an ass
towards
she's an exotic dancer musician you can
get some of her tracks on itunes she's a
dj
she's a snake charmer performer all
around
she's moderate she's basically modern
day type of person you gotta have
you know it's like a gig gig economy
yeah she's like the p diddy who is like
the female mexican p diddy
uh this is someone who's probably upset
he wasn't named of who he would like to
kiss
who is this tomatoes uh congrats on 100
episodes we miss you down here at the
mother lode
particularly theo come back and you too
slob on the knob sloppy shop we miss you
boys
kisses congrats
he's so stupid who is that that's andrew
santino
you didn't know who that was no do we
know other redheads
i just thought it was some guy you knew
no dude
he misses you not me but he but he
seemed like he was joking
[Laughter]
we miss you come here
he's looking good damn he looks good huh
what did he get i guess it look he got
work done he's got some fillers yeah
he gets that fx money yeah he's got that
fx money man yeah a little dicky too
much
now he looks like a kardashian uh wow
that's awesome man ever so everybody's
just sending those thank you
they're sending the congratulations
videos
oh great it's cool
you can't can't rip off them like did
you get that song nick uh yeah yeah
this [ __ ] is so hard i want you to just
i want you to think you're in the club
your cheeks are out theo your cheeks are
out have you seen craig's news live
don't be scared to turn that [ __ ] up
nick let him get his cheeks out
feel it who is this good boy
[Music]
make a
[Music]
from my wallet
[Music]
big
[Music]
[Music]
i need everything
[Music]
[Music]
super thick
[Music]
come on
[Music]
my [ __ ] is super bad and she's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i didn't yeah
well you know we'll call it whatever but
i took the money from our zoo in mexico
and put it into the music
that's why the ostriches didn't get
delivered
modern-day sugar night bro look at you
yeah yeah sugar nice
good night stevie at night
that's how i stole your joke that day
okay it's all right it was a good text
yeah what should a music video get a
marching band damn
man we actually got another uh video to
debut
uh from from the album uh actual music
video too
a music video let's hear a dog damn we
straight record studio now
we like cot 107.
i haven't seen this either oh
[ __ ] and she was like five foot
something
a little rambunctious dms
[Music]
and i even tried to call her kateem but
it still didn't matter cause she left me
on scene
that girl so bad so beautiful the way
she walked way she talked like a movie
role
hotter than wasabi on the sushi roll and
all the guys are in her dm's life
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
since the first time
oh
y'all got me wet i'm sweating
that's my favorite song i think yeah
that's a great song that one the hannah
barrett one's my favorite
oh hannah baron goes hard too oh wow
when chin hits that out drive all the
way to alabama i get chills
i appreciate it jim went in on those
vocals huh chin take us through that
if i go if i do vocals i'll go all the
way in for sure all the way in
all the way in you wrote those lyrics
[ __ ] no i uh double rounds did
yeah okay you went all the way i'll take
those lyrics
how crazy is this little brows entered a
white rapper only contest on cats and
now he's doing a whole album with us did
you hear the story of how like he
came to do that video i thought he met a
few at an
aaa meeting or some [ __ ] i actually went
to go get chick-fil-a on a sunday night
didn't realize it was sunday pulled up
to the parking lot realized everything
was closed
decided to record a rap and that's how
it happened wow that's his origin story
right there
chick-fil-a is closed i'm gonna enter a
white rapper contest
what a great stuff a lot of white
rappers start yeah that's how most start
frustration from chick-fil-a damn man
i've got that [ __ ] sunday
logic they all started like that this
chick-fil-a's clothes about to show
these [ __ ]
and then he ended up living like blocks
from the studio yeah like he lives
dude and then what we're saying is the
guy is a stalker
what we're saying is we filed a
restraining order against him but think
about it we got [ __ ] mike stud
jelly roll yup [ __ ] paw wall on the
side people shout
dogs people's nuts that's crazy man
nuts dog i'm sick of seeing these bald
dudes on the streets i'm not man
i love them and if you're bald you're
welcome in my area not mine man
do something about it 66 percent of men
start to lose their hair by 35
and i'm sick of seeing it there's
something you can do i'm talking about
forehands.com
one stop shop for hair loss brendan skin
care sexual wellness what do you need
man
brandon you got weiner problems barry
barnyard whatever your name is what i'm
telling you about you got wiener
problems
yes i do i know you do that's we need
four hymns all you gotta do is answer a
few quick questions
then a real doctor medical professional
looks at it
let you know ships it to your crib and
you can save some money go to
for hims.com cats that's for him.com
cats dog look here's the thing everybody
wants a body to be right yep
everybody wants that extra you know that
extra knuckle in their buckle
yeah but everybody everybody wants that
little extra chirp in their slurp
everybody so what i'm telling you right
now is today hems is giving you their
best offer yet
oh the best if you're not happy with the
results after 90 days hems will give you
a full
refund that's all your money coming back
get your first visit absolutely free go
to for hims.com
kats that's for hims.com precipitation
products require an online consultation
with healthcare provider who will
determine if prescription is
restricted supply c website fully sales
and important safety information
remember that's foreign
cats sometimes you got to get a look man
i know sometimes you get in trouble with
your spouse and you got to get them uh
something a nice piece of jewelry yeah
nothing says i'm sorry like a diamond
you can't be like i'm sorry and give
your girl a little uh
yeah or not that but um fake gold you
know a copper uh
wristlet yeah don't give her some fake
jewel get that real hitter with
thebluenow.com
bluenow.com you can celebrate all live
special moments say somebody's having a
child somebody's
you know burying a grandparent dog
celebrate your skin through 2020 with a
fat ass diamond ring
son yup get your wife get your husband
get your man husband if you a man as
well then you got a
male husband get your male wife or
whatever a ring or whatever yeah who
says men can't wear diamond rings yep
what i'm telling you is you it could be
an engagement funeral yeah get your
little twink up [ __ ] diamond uh pinky
earrings y'all stay woke baby what i'm
telling you is that this man
it's time to mark that special occasion
from engagement anniversaries birthdays
whatever
yes never settle at bluenile.com choose
from
more than 100 000 ethically sourced
these have not been drug mule these
having these aren't no blood diamonds
gia graded diamonds in every shape and
size
with an endless selection of settings to
help you design the ring of her
dreams blue now has simple online tools
that let you choose the diamond shape
size clarity as well as any setting
style blue niles
bench jewelers will then build your
perfect engagement ring
each is one of a kind blue nile is now
offering you guys
an exclusive section of lightbox
lab-grown diamond fashion jewelry this
premium product line was released just
in time for the holidays
and makes a memorable gift yep if it's a
last minute gift you're not sure
just make the smart choice get jewelry
blue nile lightbox
lab grown collection includes new and
exclusive styles of earrings
pendants bracelets and rings assessably
priced and set in 14
k gold king and the sting listeners when
you spend 500
you save 50 this podcast exclusive is
only good through december
and includes engagement that's what's
going to code k-a-t-s dog christians
coming up i want a diamond ring thiel
that's code k-a-t-s plus every order is
insured
ships for free and arrives in discreet
packaging that won't give it away what's
inside
shop stress-free and find your forever
peace you won't have to go out another
crowd
you won't have to go out and catch covid
go to bluenile.com
today a hundred dollars once a week
before once a week hundred weeks what
are your guys's favorite
uh moments from the first hundred
oh the iggy azalea wrath has always been
my favorite
though
that might have been the funniest moment
on cats you know my heart yeah
spit it dog [ __ ] [ __ ] iggy oh no
iggy iggy [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you got too many good two weeks
suspension iggy iggy [ __ ] illy whether
the amazon tasters kitty silly billy
popping pillies smoking liquor swiss
[ __ ] like this feeling
look at my crack after shock
that's all i got that's all i got
[Laughter]
but then right after that was one of the
the years ago
uh sketch and that might have been the
hardest years ago i've never last so
hard
you know when you send me the countdowns
nick i could not wait to post that i
laughed
so [ __ ] hard years ago that was years
ago
we're going to do a spoken word for us
now right
and tell us what we're about to hear
it's just a freestyle
okay i'm just gonna pick it up freestyle
so let me sit back
go ahead marshall okay
years ago they tried to years ago
they tried to put me in it
oh this is did you want to try to read
something from your book
yeah okay
oh my gosh the first comment on that
video
you can't blame him not after what they
tried to do it to him years ago
i hope he's doing well uh i actually
have an update on marshall
oh what happened he passed away i was a
huge huge goal to get him
here for the 100th episode i wanted to
have little brows record a song years
ago on the verse but then him walk in
we've been on the phone and stuff and
yeah he said his whole family got
covered and his dad who was elderly
passed away like
two weeks ago oh well this got sad but i
mean
like in loving memory uh he he was like
man i i
i would i'm totally down i've been
watching you guys i'm digging it but i'm
just kind of grieving right now
all right dude
i've laughed so [ __ ] hard there's
been times where i'm laughing
so hard they're not even a show i just
keep laughing
yeah i've i'll yeah i'll see you live
starting and then i'll get hard
crazy 100 episode once a week 100 weeks
oh man over two years right yeah oh
here's freaking riley
riley mel hey brendan hey theo
congratulations on y'all's 100th episode
of king and steve is he so serious uh
brendan it was super nice to meet you
when you were out here in nashville with
the entire gang
thanks buddy um theo
man thank you so much for everything oh
chris um
for having me on the show become your
little asian side piece
you know i love it um okay
yeah just thank you so much for
everything um
i mean both of y'all and the rice rocket
flare up for a second can't wait to
continue more in the in the new year
well that was probably the time to tell
you you're fired
buzz buzz you heard it from me here
first riley you're fired
why did you say that no we'll have him
back in soon man whenever we get uh
whenever we do a solo episode thank you
riley
appreciate it bro yeah appreciate the
hard work man very alarming to be
and i'm not i'm not saying yes but to be
somebody that seems like him
uh-huh also driving and recording
himself what about him is dangerous
that's fair
dangerous about just some of the ways he
seems
yes why the stereotypes i'm not saying
that brendan okay i'll say it for you
okay
why does he look like he has astigmatism
or he just
he's i could see sir i could see it
being alarming to some people
yeah like if he was my uber driver i'd
be alarmed
okay i would leave him a two star you
would yes
hmm derek you got any uh favorite
memories from uh
your time on the show yeah that's a good
question
i liked when theo thought that we just
let some lady have
come on her face
come on man and i'm like what dude he's
like dude
we can't have this on the show i'm like
what's wrong with her we look in
dog seaman all
somebody's seaming that lady why'd they
do it did they say well
that might
oh yeah was right
we thought it was someone's on did we
still have that we still had that video
i forgot about that yeah that one
that one [ __ ] that was funny oh that was
amazing i don't remember
anything i hope he's out there
we do so many shows you remember all of
it i forgot about that that was
hilarious dude
cuz yeah you guys are all like she had a
question you guys were like trying to
answer her questions we were dead
serious
i was like yeah she like couldn't find a
man i was like this is what you gotta do
girl
here we go there we go there's a lot of
stuff going on here she's got that
mascara like your boy said derek
zoom in on that i hold the [ __ ] dude
there's [ __ ] all over
no one's noticed this that's semen isn't
it
she's not a [ __ ] cinnamon roll is she
that's not icing theo
bro this is a man dude that's not a man
she's making a porno
and this was the end of it you know what
don't cut out the part i said in the
beginning because i was trying to
go back to this look at the whole thing
going on here the blonde hair doesn't
match the rest of her hair
this is a man's face and he got busted
on he must be off cigarettes
oh god he's flying spirit airlines he's
off secrets
he works at a doll factory this is a
young fella man
this is a nice young man who enjoys
pizza
and getting loads on his face well who
knows dude
i'm a detective way too much 48. i
hey case off you're a detective dude
you're the worst detective you've seen
six minutes praising this young lass
dude what are you talking about he said
a couple nice
tits i thought about taking her out for
a good time the first thing i said was
that this young
fella zoom in
you did call it hey hold on how does no
one
run in the cameras see the [ __ ] semen
on this dude's face
bro what is this cert turned into man i
don't want to be a part of anything like
this man
yeah let's not well let's put this on
this time but i ain't doing this stuff
where i'm looking at semen on some fella
man
it might be sweat though that ain't
sweat that's thick thick sweat out of
somebody's nuts
it is dude i'm serious man we can do it
this time i'm not looking at this kind
of stuff i didn't come here to look at
this
oh my god then
oh i [ __ ] forgot about that the guy
that was a man
that was definitely a man you need to
forget that if dude dressed like a woman
is a
uh is a man yeah you remember the first
episode when we had chin's aunt on
and i was so crunk for his aunt he's hot
yeah she's batty
wait last episode didn't we talk about
how theo might have hooked up with
theo's i mean chins on because she was
in i don't know
yeah yeah she was a korean it was i just
remember it was a korean lady and i
remember
we tried to get involved and have some
sort of sexual interaction but
she wasn't into it no she was into it
brendan yeah were you not into it huh
that's other friends of yours
i will say this about this korean lady i
remember her legs didn't dv
they wouldn't her her lips open up they
were kind of like you know chopsticks
are kind of like at the top they're kind
of just
just like that she's pigeon-footed they
wouldn't like you had to they would just
how to snap them open
well no no you didn't have to
and you wouldn't do that and you never
did it yeah you don't but uh
it was just there was no way to have sex
because her just her leg it was like
trying to work
yeah i was like trying to get those
sticks apart and they wouldn't come
apart and you're like oh this doesn't
work so now
you want to tell chin
[Laughter]
here it is right here no this was
another one of my uh favorite moments
um these these guys oh yeah
why did we do this it was it was your
birthday yeah we had a cookie baby
he just got back from hawaii
yeah it is
yeah those guys were great i was feeling
myself remember i kept clowning them too
yeah when they laughed i was all mean
about it oh yeah because they went one
song too long
yeah i got old fast yeah i think it's
it's you do two songs when you're there
two two and out and they
we remember killing them to leave when
you stay for that third song it's rough
yeah you remember when you're a girl you
got her the uh quinceanera singers what
was it
yeah for her birthday oh yeah the myriad
was like during the middle of covid
people are so mean to me online really
yeah that's gonna spread your super
spreader
[ __ ] mariachi band mexicans don't get
it man
i'm trying to think of what other it's
science what else was a good seg
a good clip do you guys have any
favorites
i i i literally until you bring him up i
get there's so many man there's so
[ __ ] many
this show's so [ __ ] funny i just
forget i think do you remember any nick
uh i'm trying to look at the uh you have
no excuse though i have ct
and it's well documented yeah my words
yeah but you just
are you do you have it have you been
tested for it
no yeah what are you talking about i
lose my keys and stuff
yeah but that's dude you could just
everybody loses their keys yeah
sometimes we forget to fill up our tank
yeah right there yeah i lost my
totally i lost my keys this morning here
we go here we go bubba
i don't know it could just be i don't
want to say it but
but say it ignorance
you know what i'm saying like i don't
think before you fought you were the guy
who
knew it all remember oh do you guys
remember when we set up
yeah jim went on that date with hot carl
and here's how carl now and
you destroyed
100 episodes of the king and the sting
man i'm absolutely loving it
shout out to the man with the million
dollar mullet theo vaughn shout out to
the leader of the thick gang and the man
with the mean kick game brendan shaw
yeah send my love to the culture corner
tell chin i said what's up shout out to
my bubba nick davis i love y'all man
100 episodes cheers to a thousand more
baby
hell yeah jelly roll he didn't say
chappelle but that's okay
okay that's awesome thanks jelly yeah
but let's not let chin off the hook so
remember we took
chin took that young lady out spent
about a grand of our money
and then at the end she he was like yeah
she's [ __ ] hot check out those tits
and then was like oh i'm married you
know that she was that
that's how we found out chin had a girl
but this also now a
true you thought he was gay for a second
yeah oh yeah
we thought he was coming out pause for
longer and i i almost ruined his outing
because i went you're gay
damn bro he was trying to be gay and you
stopped
another great one and i'm almost have
the video up instagram to make me log in
but uh the first time we were introduced
uh to noodling uh we we met that fellow
who wasn't
tv camera ready oh yeah oh yeah that
dude that had his shirt off all up in
the video yeah saint tricholus this day
the body adios yeah saint tits yeah and
he's all up in the water trying to catch
some fish
oh yeah he'd be under the water come up
really seductively yeah
that brack is santa you got to get in
there
those boys don't want to get caught
let's get a shot of this guy why did you
do my man like that
he wasn't tv prep
what was going on there oh no that
dude's hanging out for the wrong way
i think his noodling's different than
the rest of people
it's okay the girls come at night after
that old man leaves
oh i'll be back in the morning i had a
good time timmy gonna be back tomorrow
when i leave my shirt and pants
[Laughter]
his tits are water logged huh look at
his whole skin
he exploded and dead and here's our last
congratulations video
lots of characters that didn't make the
show shout out stefan
and uh but the man himself browsed
your look alike cats in the wild oh he
was sexy what up gangsters is brows
congratulations on 100 episodes we love
you guys so much thanks for being the
best podcast out there
i'm in the studio right now which is my
kitchen
um because i'm broke till that album
money hits but either way
congratulations go get go get that man
man's album it's on itunes now cats
king the sting album and all the revenue
uh of that goes to the artist uh lil
brow really quarterbacked and produced
it so
a lot to him and then splitting it with
all the other submitters so yeah man
go support hey man yeah it's a talented
dude
he [ __ ] came up man yeah for him
chick-fil-a works miracles when they're
closed
that's true that's why they close yeah
that's why they close some miracles can
happen man
what else do we what else happened on
the show i'm trying to remember what
else here's actually uh
a new one um cat's sister pointed out
kind of a cats in the wild so my sister
and i were watching a
basketball game between long beach and
lmu
and she said that this guy looks like
you two had a kid
his name is pepe oh yeah that's a good
name that's clearly tiger when he's 18.
so that's cool damn that hair is long
lmu that lupe jersey dude i know those
shorts
what are these flags new zealand
great britain and uh i don't know what
the middle one is
it's great britain and new zealand
though oh why were you
you your sister was scouting for some
dudes or what uh we were just watching a
game
yeah oh she's talking to one of the
homies on the team
but let's just say she was watching for
one person and she ended up watching
pepe and let me guess it wasn't the
white boy coming off the bench you can
shoot a three
the token white dude who's good at three
probably not that's a good guess
yeah yeah that's australia
yeah and then new zealand was so close
huh wow i guess it's just no uh
wow you been in new zealand
no you haven't yeah i did stand up there
it's fantastic
is it like the exact same thing as
australia no way better
really listen i love australia but it's
like australia you feel like you're
in a nicer america everybody's really
cool all the women are really hot
but then in new zealand you know that's
where they shoot [ __ ]
lord of the rings jurassic park it felt
like i was in jurassic park
wow yeah and what do they have they have
different what all kind of different
vegetables and everything yep
wow in a different currency too and i
got [ __ ] laughed out of a coffee shop
because i tried paying with my
australian money and they really went in
on me mm-hmm
i didn't know that there was like a gang
war when you walked through get over the
border
oh man they started calling me a yankee
and
what does that mean i think i think it's
like their version of cracker or daddy
yankee is the worst one
poppy yankee yeah i can't remember any
of our old clips man
i just remember our first episode chin's
aunt
thick sweat mm-hmm yeah what else did we
talk about when you guys brought my dad
on
oh oh yeah we had a family reunion yeah
when you and when theo asked if he did
the crime
that's right yeah
he was a good yeah he said look what did
he say he had to get him he said he goes
put it this way
i studied law and got myself out
[Laughter]
that's an og answer i mean he definitely
did it
he either did it or he got framed for it
far the only person whose family has not
been represented is chappelle's
we tried to reach out to your dad to get
a video but we just couldn't get one i'm
sorry
it's okay oh okay crying but don't be
sad man we got
a surprise that's what happens sometimes
chappelle we love you we got a special
in-studio guest oh yeah oh gee triple
hey
and did you do it whatever you went to
prison for
legit questions well i mean
yeah that's a that's a hell of a
question
for my dad hey man dude we should have
made some free uh your dad's name
t-shirts oh my god he should have
free kevin free kevin yeah his name is
big kev
what's up oh wow what's his real name
though
kevin oh big kev yep free bossolini
black that would have been dope if we'd
have made this show
no a lot of people may be confused at
what we're talking about because that
was uh the family reunion uh
patreon episode uh yeah so so that's
still available there
what have you been doing during the
pandemic man i feel like we haven't even
asked man i've been like i just came
from nashville yesterday that was that's
where i was at oh yeah why are you just
going all over the country
just doing stuff i gotta keep doing
something you're just hustling hustling
yeah it's like i gotta do something like
i was doing my boy
in the nfl darren bates uh his podcast
he he just started the podcast he was
like you wanna come down
i got you went and saw the game and then
did it was me and another guy named two
fonts
two right two font skipper and white
skipper yeah what's he do
linebacker oh dope yeah no dn the end
they're all huge oh
yeah they're all big dudes huge dudes
but that was fun but oh my god one of
them said to me he said uh
because darren was like yo my boys play
quarterback he was like you a
quarterback bro
i was like yeah man this [ __ ] looked
like a rolly polly
[Laughter]
look at a [ __ ] 30. yeah in high
school bro
yeah i'm sorry i didn't keep it up well
you should have said to baker mayfield
he lit them boys up bro
[ __ ] them up but that was crazy game
to be at man that was cool yeah what was
that game like uh
was it it was in nashville in nashville
i mean they're one of the only people
with fans so you had to sit up top
but yeah they got wax man baker mayfield
you're good yeah he's good he's gonna
get that extension
so did he actually look at obviously i
haven't seen him playing this year
they're nine and three they're balling
yeah they're gonna make the playoffs and
obj's out right obj is out juice was
killing him they're better without him
jones the guy with the law you know the
law firm looking at names i'm surprised
your boy doesn't go on busting with the
boys because they're all tied
they're all they're definitely setting
it up i don't know because him and i was
i saw
i talked to him on the phone that's our
guy like a serial killer man
yeah he looks like a serial killer oh
dude he was laying in bed and he was
just like this
no he's a good looking dude yeah post
game after face though he just played
yeah it's called ct
yeah i i recognize that from a mile away
a million mile stare baby
what else happened in here cat we almost
set you up with did we ever set you up
with anybody in here
no i think it was a safety issue when we
looked into it yeah
yeah that's right was there ever any
moments where you had any
um almost had a fling with anyone in
here how to fling with anyone in it
in here no no no what does that mean in
here now
uh in the other show yes my boyfriend oh
that's the guy from
that's right that's right that's right
yeah
this is depressing i'm just doing the
math i'm just like
i know i'm just trying to figure out
what i'm just you know i'm just
no just ask yeah that's i was just like
i was trying to think if you ever had a
crush on anybody in here or if you ever
but then i forgot that your boyfriend
um we talked about him last week yeah
yeah i just forgot
huh yeah that's right have you ever have
been attracted to anybody in here
i mean when i didn't realize you had a
tail piece on you for the longest
oh my god the day we found out that you
had a badass i think
eric's one that knew because you gotta
call me flat ass yeah
and then derek was like one day bro you
you look like meg ryan
caked up yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
you guys went on that
you got the mail you know what you said
yeah yeah
i got a couple packages yeah that's
right
the day i discovered you got a tail
piece it's pretty fun dragging that
wagon baby to jay in the tray boo boo
yeah this is though this is like one of
episodes on a sitcom you remember the uh
like on any fresh prince or the cosby
show where they'd be like
we'll go on location next episode
because we save some here
yeah so where are you off to next day uh
see just got back from nashville and
then
back to baltimore when i leave here and
then phoenix because phoenix you can do
stand up yup
that was phoenix is [ __ ] lit dude
stand up live is the [ __ ] yeah
now your partner in crime a son is he
full isis
can bring him up on his instagram yeah
get this yeah look at him now
i reported him several times until
there's a vaccine i've reported
several times he looks like a mechanic
for ieds
he looks like a mechanic for boeing
that's going to fly into a [ __ ]
building
into him and they fix it yeah do you
spell his last name uh a-h-m-a-d
i-i-i-s
yeah just as like a protest or he looks
interesting
like a tick tock bit right where he
won't shave until the
uh vaccine is out yeah and he's gotten
really woke
real well yeah he's [ __ ] that's what
happens when you stay in the bay area
yep oh is he in the bay area yeah he's
back home oh it'll do it yes i haven't
seen him man
it's nice to deal all the first comics
i've seen besides adam ray bro
i am nobody coming when are you seeing
other comics really that's a good point
actually i did a show a couple weeks ago
in at a bar out here restaurant in la
and it was the first time i'd seen it
was like michael linochie and
uh mark hayes a couple of guys momento
first time i've seen anybody yeah
how was that it was weird i just forgot
that i was like oh yeah i haven't seen
these guys in six months yeah i forgot
hanging and like hanging around with
other [ __ ] and i've been doing
i've been doing the road like a
[ __ ]
yeah i'm about my crew then you're doing
good brandon
yeah it's sorry it's you and tim dillon
and like yeah sorry
no then a bunch of other comics are just
scared to say they're doing the wrong
yeah they're doing the right they're not
promoting
all it is is you guys just keep going
back and forth from salt lake city to
boise
that's all it is we're going to do
phoenix and salt lake and then boise
we just keep doing the same spots every
week
and then i'll go down to nashville yeah
but yeah man it was just awesome being
around [ __ ] comics again doug
yeah you know what i'm saying now are
you going to stay out of la or you you
know i'm waiting to come back
i'm waiting for the store baby that's
like the home it's like when the store
opens up it's like all right if the
store opens up everything else will open
up
but [ __ ] man it should be a hot second
before the school opens up that's why
it's taking me six months yeah that's
crazy i think it shouldn't
be still might be six months nuts has
anybody
give quit comedy that you know of while
you've been uh good question
i mean which i don't know it's hard to
say because we're not backing it yet and
do they say they quit
or they're just kind of like oh i moved
to denver yeah all right well you're out
you're not even in the race yeah because
you're not i don't to idaho it's like
all right well where are you getting up
dog you
quit yeah so well you're getting up
nowhere if you ain't in the cities that
open you ain't getting up bro you're
lying you're getting up yeah that's true
you ain't getting up
but arizona's popping though phoenix is
popping so we're so we're so until
you're where are you laying low till it
opens up
baltimore because you can get up there
what's that magoos out there the goobies
they got my goobies
and they got uh and then just like
little bar shows but they're like still
open they're like letting people at
least
come inside right what i'm saying so
that's the main thing it's like
just anybody coming i gotta be honest
i'm surprised you're like you're girl
pregnant
dude she's still locked up somewhere
yeah she's [ __ ] screaming right now
no
i'm trying to get a pregnant bro i want
to get a pregnant but it's like
you can't eat i mean i don't even like
can you go to the hot like they won't
even let people have funerals right now
bro a lot of sperms is stressed out too
yeah yeah my sperms [ __ ] work they're
running
the other direction the sperm got the
mask on oh they started
on you yeah swimming back stream yeah
well but it was nice bro like i like uh
we were hanging with i'm going to say
his name but where i was with during the
weekend with adam ray in phoenix
and just in the green room and you just
like see a young comic
like [ __ ] up yeah and it was like oh i'm
back i'm back
some guy's in the city hey listen what a
guy he looks it out of brain he's like
he said
he's a man i was trying to get the times
the girl weekend but they gave me you
and adam goes oh [ __ ] dude is your
sentence over
is that it that was it that's all you
had to say
look at it sorry that was nine minutes
later instagram was being
but that is wild yeah bro look the hair
is even crazier the boy's going
crazy yeah he's going absolutely but
look at that million dollar house
i wish the house they call him oh they
call him oman benjamin
[Laughter]
he's got that lebron hairline dude i'm
telling you wishes yeah lebron
get this guess that larry david ice's
dude he's about to be teaching people
how to uh try to get to another
dimension
is that yeah that's his mom on the right
i mean yeah that's not
his mom falling bro yeah let me see here
again
they're loaded that's why derek that's
why hassan's like laying in the cup yeah
he can lay in the cut
yeah he can chill his dad's a rocket
scientist it makes the biggest ribs
you've ever seen in this world really
his dad literally works for nasa
when i saw him first thing i said hey
dog what do you think of people that
think the earth is flat he got mad
he started laughing remember oh yeah he
started laughing at me alright cool take
it easy now he's like that is so stupid
brendon yeah
what yep dang his dad has an accent yeah
it's pretty oh
thick accents where's his mom yeah super
thick
yeah hassan's still singles [ __ ] bro
when i look at the house i feel single
that makes me want to break up with my
girl when i look at him yeah i am
oh you're single yeah i'm single man
yeah you've been single
it's tough to meet people in copenhagen
man well not in nashville though you
guys are [ __ ] litty like a thing yeah
naturally you can live it's a it's
definitely a different vibe but i don't
know if anybody's really trying to like
make moves during cove like like real
forward progress
moves no what are you gonna just netflix
and chill that's about it but with
are you once things open like the store
is popping like la midnight doesn't be
popping
maybe well let's say it is you're gonna
wish you're back here
i can just come back good point yeah you
can always come back it's not my
apartment is here it's open every i mean
i have the keys to it and i can just
come back to it you can stay with me too
i got my place stay with me though
you're right i can't thank you i
appreciate that man i might stay over
there
and tiger might wrestle you all day yeah
that's a good point dude you did put him
to work when it was yeah
that fine little one who's that little
shorty brennan's instagram oh boston
run yeah that little thought that little
thick boy
damn [ __ ] working too bro
bring up that little oh yeah no no one
more there you go there we go
shorty working is
definitely one of the best moments from
from uh the old studio
this this sad man who's smoking weed by
himself oh
yeah remember when we did relationship
advice
that was my favorite segment we helped
so many people from him uh yeah yeah we
we definitely should
smoking some weed and i got caught
before doing that and she wasn't happy
about it but
i thought it helps i just started again
and i haven't told her yet so
the question is should i tell her who
gets mad at someone's smoking weed
especially
how old is this [ __ ] in every
clip
why do i get a blowout like if i get
that jersey shore blowout
looks nine years old brandon changes up
his look
every three months what filter is that
doug that's that fine filter
is it brendan or stefan i don't
too dude i'll tell you about this if
you're getting high and you got a wife
a little bit of weed to make your wife
feel like a brand new woman
you know take the sex to a different
place dude yeah she's complaining about
weed to get her high and then eat her
ass like
you just groceries the guy nine
different pieces of advice man
i'm hoping something sticks i throw a
lot of things
and i hope he connects to one so i've
been
yeah that guy was great we'll try to get
an update from that man
that guy messaged me a lot after that
happened it didn't go well if you want
the update i'll give it to you
we've ruined his life and that's why
i still love you guys but my wife left
me but that [ __ ] didn't
who knows maybe he's better off uh if
you can find his instagram for me
i love those old clips nikki on the
others yeah we're we're scrolling
through the instagram now that we're in
[ __ ] that's funny relationship advice i
always thought we were helping people
we were we should get more of them we
don't have it anymore do we send them in
i mean it's a
it's a lot of guys sending in the same
question how do i meet girls over
kovalev
i i've read that question 50 [ __ ]
times yeah man we hit
i don't know if you guys should do that
i literally just said you ruined a guy's
life
yeah i'll take people seriously you know
heavy
yeah i thought i was helping people but
but what but you tried
well maybe we should set him up you know
now he's a single dude
yeah not that he's not the easiest cell
but you know
that was a nice guy too i thought that
man was a nice guy a decent man
decent man yeah remember when we did the
one chip challenge
and everyone died oh my god the one chip
challenge right of that
it was like three weeks ago uh but uh
this one was good damn the man let's do
some ds
but the man that i'm with right now does
he have you hostage
why are you whispering he doesn't make
any noise in the bedroom she got that
nose ring let me say this won't you put
a little sign on your nose
so speak up what kind of dude like you
want a freak
in the bedroom yeah and a normal dude on
the street is he a chatty kathy
then you get into that bedroom you
expect that turns into a deaf jeff yeah
deaf jeff yeah and that's your fault are
you looking for an
order are you looking for somebody who's
[ __ ] are you looking for frederick
douglass
are you looking for [ __ ] fred frank
douglas you're looking for a friend
you want [ __ ] or you want chatter you
can't sometimes you can't have it at all
the guy's trying to get his nut off and
please his girl she's looking for a
play-by-play everything that he's doing
you think i'm joe buck or joe [ __ ] dude
just wants to chill and bust nuts girl
yeah listen to a book on tape get you
some of the mayor pogba
listen to the king and sting while you
get pounded
i gotta say the instagram cut down
stepped up when i took over
that was funny though god we are helping
people out though
doing the lord's work i miss it man miss
that show
send it send it no you turn around buddy
we got you back on
i'd love to do more relationship advice
and flop my aunts we just like want
videos and uh
and uh of your of your aunts not just
pictures because
it kind of gets to be the same thing a
little bit damn that one was from the
first episode
yeah see that that's in theo's old
studio
and before we go we're gonna launch a
new segment flaunt my
aunt this is my aunt debbie she's on the
left dude who's mr steal your man on the
right though
i'm distracted by your by your grandma
with the booty perked out
she's in the texas tuxedo bro
with the gold change she looks like
carrie van gaal
like she hung out around the alamo you
know what i'm saying a lot of boys
grandma looks like she has a rolex
underneath that [ __ ] texan tuxedo she
looked like she hung around staple
centers in this in the 60s
shout out to your [ __ ] swaggy p
grandma bro hey can you leave her alone
she's dying still kicking love you
grandma
oh [ __ ] nick that was your grandma that
was an experience can you leave her
alone
uh oh look at that uh garbage fell card
too that's cool what was that
what do you think a little non-zx going
gay oh oh
i thought it was pretty cool man and
also just right on time you know what
i'm saying he's just perfect timing in
there even if you're not
about coming out yeah just to boost
tickets though really
okay you oh you want more of a gay fan
base i don't know dude yeah but you
think little nas
you thought it was a good move i mean
i'm sure it's a good i'm talking black
people about this i'm very making love
to men as well
but it's also a good move for his career
good move for his personal life too you
know
also most people probably knew that he
was gay or preferred man he you know his
office gave off that
i won the outfit he has that kind of
like sometimes to me like a gay
uh some gay man they have that like
they've been
kind of just looking for sugar a little
bit
you know i'm saying like their mouth
kind of has like that little sweetness
yeah it's
got a little sugar in there yeah that's
sweet and low yeah like they just
[ __ ] just polished off the lemon
about eight minutes ago
the last rib and just sucked that
bad boy dry yeah they got horses in the
back
whose birthday whose birthday that's
good [ __ ] guys
man we've been doing the damn thing damn
fun
show man it's a fun [ __ ] show
100 episodes 100 weeks
work plus patreon yeah a lot of work a
lot of work a lot of work for nick and
chin
hey man bro and the editors yeah shout
out shout out man behind the scenes joe
rubicaba
he's been editing this episode since uh
we moved to this studio and he is
he's a he's a pro he's a pro what's his
last
they call him the chupacabra of editing
yeah i knew it
and he's really i mean he says you can't
even see him but he's and he's rocking a
ponytail uh during covet times too
amen what a power move we should get a
picture of him so that people can see
him in the future
for sure for sure well next time i'm in
here i'm going to have a man bun and
some highlights so get your mind right
changing my hair style
and deer what are you going for with
your hair styling are you going to braid
it up maybe braid it up i don't know man
i might i don't
want to do something crazy get some
extensions i'll get a [ __ ] jared curl
or a weave ooh what about an s curl
that'd be a glass girl yeah
a [ __ ] ice cube a jerry curl i i've
long said that jerry crowley needs to
make a comeback yes there's one guy on
instagram
that has it but that uh outside of that
i haven't seen it that wet look
the cb40 look yes mc gusto
mc gusto yeah do it dog that dw40 look
[ __ ] yeah
you actually said it to me theo like six
years ago did it really yeah you were
like i had a friend like then you were
like hey man
bring the jerry curl back nobody's doing
it anymore just like that because
he's the only person on your mind still
waiting still waiting in that crate
we're still waiting for somebody to have
it i think i'll bring it back bro why
not why not what else am i doing with
this [ __ ] thing
yeah there's also nothing else to do
open up man
we hurting out here who's i don't yeah i
don't know what is it like is there a
different vibe in the black community at
all about the cova virus
no we i will say this
i will say this because i do know a lot
of black people who are like i ain't
going back to work bro
you know i don't speak like that too i
know a lot of white people
like exactly you know what i'm saying so
i get it but bro i think
mostly everybody's like bro let me let
me make some money man yep let me make
some money
yeah i ain't talking like a million like
i mean let me make a paycheck
come on dog let me get out and do
something
that's always a paycheck man just crazy
out there it's tough on the streets
but not in here baby honey not in here
we getting it done man thank you guys
man keep touching me bro
i love you too [ __ ] touch me a
thousand more episodes dog
yep thank you guys for putting together
the new studio derrick thank you so much
for coming in bro
i [ __ ] love you yeah man mr chappelle
small the beans bro listen smaller beans
if you want to [ __ ] find your boy
that's where i'm at man listen to
spoiler means you can catch derek on
there and
uh with a son tour no sometimes not i
mean since cove it happened no now it's
just guess man songs on the real fly
list so he's playing on the podcast oh
yeah yeah got rick glassman coming up a
lot of people fun people so spoil the
beans come check it out it's a good time
check it out nick davis thank you so
much nick stewart looks great brother
thank you
chin thank you thank you cat the editors
thank you guys the listeners thank you
youtube bro yeah thank y'all bro y'all
did this this is y'all bro
thank you started with a dream did it no
it started the nordstrom rack it
actually started with us making fun of
each other yep
it started with brian missing finding
the kid i need a co-host
and you would come on and you're really
funny
we would rip each other up we'd light
each other up and then we decided to do
a
podcast and in the belly room i remember
that one day where y'all laid each other
up on stage yep i remember that day was
crazy
oh yeah that was fun that was fun that
got
bread and i off on the wrong foot to be
honest because he thought i edited it
in favor of theo he started though he
started the when he
he didn't get me lighting theo up he
missed my first two jokes
so yeah he's got the steel lights what
the [ __ ]
we've all missed those brendan i was
like what the [ __ ] dude
we missed those every year i hated nick
when we first started
i hated dick when we first started now i
love nick thanks brother nick's one of
the best producers in the game
i talk to nick all the time now oh with
this cause you talked to doesn't mean
anything brandon no me and nick are boys
okay okay that's fine you got nick's
picks on below the belt
yeah i gotta keep turning in i quit
betting actually i lost three thousand
dollars this year
didn't have a great weekend last weekend
either so i feel you man thankfully i
wasn't in that i can't i'm out
yeah i'm done i cashed out i'm in palm
beach end of the year
closing this [ __ ] year off palm
beach florida
i'll be the palm beach improv uh
december 29th through january 2nd
you can see me doing a live event with
uh chelsea lynn
who plays tammy in all of our videos and
that's going to be
um i believe december 14th or 16th it's
going to be one night only you watch it
live it's going to be a live streamed
event this would be fun man yeah ten
dollar ticket it's gonna be a nice
ticket hell yeah i know it's gonna be a
good time get em boys listen fans the
show's not uh
happening without you guys your
submissions all the characters
all that stuff it's cause you guys
there's a thousand more we love you guys
thanks for watching
thank you god brennan and theo fighter
and weight i got to go in and go hard in
the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrage is thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso in the case of
ritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
trapping couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want the smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in a club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string